[Musique]
la tour eiffel frappé plusieurs fois par
la foudre
au petit matin photo impressionnante
symbole d'un épisode orageux avec plus
diluvienne sur la capitale nous sommes
en plein centre de reims le courant est
si puissant que cet homme peine à
retenir son deux roues
il finit même par abandonner
oui la chaîne de télé américaine a tout
prévu
donc même l'apocalypse donc le jour où
que c'est la fin nn diffusera un
orchestre interprétant plus près de toi
mon dieu une ambiance hyper sympa c'est
un document très attendu que s'apprête à
publier le gouvernement américain le
rapport sur les ovnis le new york times
a déjà pu le consulter
cette enquête conclut qu'il n'ya aucune
preuve de l'existence des
extraterrestres
mais ce rapport n'explique pas pour
autant certains phénomènes observés par
les pilotes militaires américains c'est
quoi ce truc là ça fait des rotations à
mon dieu et ça avance contre le vent le
vent souffle à 120,9 mais regarde ça en
là encore sur la côte est près de la
floride
ces photos d'objets volants sont prises
par un copilote des objets que le
pentagone ne s'est pas identifié et qui
inquiète les pilotes hanouna n'est pas
un journaliste mais il est un médiateur
un capteur de l'air du temps un
influenceur d'opinion et qui sait s'il
ne sera pas un acteur demain de la
présentielle petit jouet précisément un
rôle durant cette campagne
présidentielle le souhaite-t-il
roule-t-il pour un candidat pour un camp
pour une idée eh bien il est ce
maintenant avec nous et je l'en remercie
grandement 6 passes cache pourtant je
vous regarde tous les matins donc un
jour cyril vous disait que la société
était bancale qu'elle porte c'est même
un peu à droite la jambe droite
est ce qu'il ya un mot qui eux qu'on
devrait un peu plus souvent utilisés on
dit la société les fractures et est ce
qu'il ya un amour le mot réconciliation
c'est quelque chose qui devrait rentrer
un petit peu plus en avant aujourd'hui
avant l'arrêt constitue un le mot
apaisement les électeurs de marine le
pen sont les plus nombreux à me regarder
quotidiennement bons essais ça fait
c'est ça j'avais déjà fait un sondage en
2017 les résultats est à peu près les
mêmes styles mélenchon et marine le pen
qui arrivait en tête et c'est vrai que
si les cds rahama presse sur la droite
pure on a plus de mal bon 19% les
physios dit qu'il a regardé des
émissions de cyril hanouna au moins une
fois par semaine à ressasser de
chiffres-clés filmée par un vidéaste
amateur
ces images montrent une femme en
tee-shirt noirs soupçonnés d'avoir volé
dans ce magasin elle prend violemment à
partie une employée du supermarché
plusieurs insultes à caractère raciste
sont proférés la jeune femme accompagnée
de deux enfants en bas âge fini par
quitter le magasin il n'y a pas plus
grande injustice que de s'en prendre à
quelqu'un pour une couleur qui n'a pas
choisi est ce que moi je me souviens pas
d'avoir choisi ma couleur je me souviens
pas de mettre rêver ou un moment dans le
ventre de mes parents il ya des boutons
j'ai choisi la couleur marge et je me
souviens pas de ça peut-être que j'ai
raté quelque chose mais je n'ai pas
choisi de couleurs comment tu peux
comprendre à quelqu'un qui n'a pas
choisi regardez l'équipe de france que
les quatre joueurs que vous nous avez
montré regardez-moi le visage de cette
équipe voilà voilà nos vainqueurs on a
qui viennent m bape est en train de
griezmann karim benzema
le comté mais cette équipe elle est
belle elle claque elle déchire mais
parce qu on a cette diversité de
bonhomme avec tous les bagages qu'ils
ont leur propre histoire leur éducation
leurs parents l'histoire de leur famille
et c'est ça la france
et c'est cette france là qui nous a
ramené une deuxième coupe du monde les
déboires de neymar victimes de la folie
de ses supporters au brésil alors que la
star regagner l'hôtel de la seleçao à
porto alegre trois adolescents ont forcé
le cordon de sécurité pour tenter de
prendre un selphy avec leur idole
un des trois est tombée et a taclé
involontairement le joueur neymar on a
même perdu ses chaussures avant de
repartir en boitant légèrement
j'ai pas encore pris ses chaudes de
gingembre
si l'on tient flammes at war oui il
parait c'est très bon pour les messieurs
c'est ce qu'on a appris
thomas a tenu à venir avec son épouse
que je trouve extrêmement ringard vieux
jeu c'est lamentable
c'est pour lui souffler les réponses et
le cottage vient qu'avec ma femme
franchement c'est moche bercy
l'accueillir mélanie page ma part qui
jouent pour la voix de l'enfant paraît
bassam à savoir un jour entre bruce
toussaint son amant
c'est que du bonheur j'ai dédié ma
détresse est très bonne mais j'aime bien
nagui parce que nagui y défend des
causes ici s'engage quoi sa révolte est
ce un rebelle
il aime pas le cancer ils n'aiment pas
les femmes violées il y va quoi il tape
fort mélanie page qui est une alcoolique
maintenant tout le monde essaie et qui
vient de vivre un nouveau moment de
solitude
pendant ce temps le conducteur rodez
saut et sans perdre de temps
il pousse de toutes ses forces la bâche
[Musique]
et il parvient à la faire entrer dans sa
petite voiture
[Musique]
les vaches indiennes sont les meilleurs
tous les médecins et les scientifiques
s'accordent pour le dire
ici on croit aux vertus thérapeutiques
de la vache sur l'homme
le responsable de cette ferme le docteur
des ja conçoit des médicaments à base
d'uriné et aussi de bouse de vache mais
déjections sont transformés conditionné
en granulés ou en gélules avant d'être
vendus dans les pharmacies du pays
y croyez-vous a effectivement cette vie
qui va reprendre et reprendre on va dire
avec plutôt la patate obligé c'est
obligé que ça reprenne avec la patate
est tellement de restriction fatalement
été serré que c'est comme un paquet de
chips quoi à part ça va péter
le corona virus est une maladie
bactérienne les sept urines de vache
détruites toutes les bactéries
d'autres sont d'ulysse de bouse de vache
pour les mêmes raisons les médecins
indiens alerte sur les traitements
alternatifs au corona vie mais vous
savez je veux demander ce que ça sentait
sur le plateau et bien cet homme sans le
bonheur bravo
on vous souhaite de vous faire du bien
n'est ce pas absolument un beaucoup de
bien et surtout foutez vous la p1
commencé à vivre